[MUSIC PLAYING]
LEIGHA JARETT: Hi, everybody.
I'm Leigha.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI: And I'm Nikita.
LEIGHA JARETT: And welcome
to the Data Cloud live demo.
If you're just joining us
from this morning's keynote
and spotlight, you heard some
of the latest innovations
we launched.
Earth Engine, Spark on Google
Cloud, PostgreSQL Interface
for Spanner, and
Vertex AI Workbench,
all to help organizations solve
their most complex data driven
challenges.
In this live demo, we're going
to take complex, fragmented
data systems and simplify
them, bringing together
data on a massive scale
to explore a real world
scenario for climate and
supply chain analytics.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI: In
order to do this,
we're going to need
the whole data team.
Say hi, everyone.
BRAD MIRO: Hello, I'm Brad.
DEREK DOWNEY: Hi, I'm Derek.
BRAD MIRO: Now, a quick
reminder, this demo
is truly live and you can
engage with us directly.
So, ask questions, say
hi in the chat window,
and hit those emojis.
LEIGHA JARETT: I think I
see some coming in now.
I see lots of hearts and fire.
A lot of people saying
hello in the chat.
Thanks, everyone,
for joining us today.
So, if you can't see
the emojis or the chat,
just go back to the
next event website
and click on the blue Join The
Interactive Experience button.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI: OK, let's
have a little fun with this.
Today, you're actually joining
us for our weekly stand
up at Cymbal Superstore.
A fictional US-based
grocery chain,
focused on sourcing
from local producers.
Like many different
industries, we
need to bring together
disparate data sources
to build resilience.
Specifically for us,
drought in the Western US
has impacted our producers
and our supply chain
has been disrupted with
decreased shipments week
over week.
We need to better understand
how to manage inventory
to prevent stock
outs, and ensure
we can scale in both how
we analyze information
and how we run our transactions.
LEIGHA JARETT: All right, team.
So, to address the supply
and scale challenges
that Nikita just mentioned, we
have four different workloads.
First, I'm going to evaluate
the best climate information
to identify at risk producers.
Then Brad will mature
our data pipelines
to transform that data.
Next, Derek will dig into
scaling our transaction
processing.
And finally, Nikita
will show how
we're gaining new insights
by evolving our data science
capabilities.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI:
Let's get into it.
And let's keep hearing
from all of you
out there, our data pros.
Leigha, you're up first.
LEIGHA JARETT: Great.
Thanks, Nikita.
So, in order to gain insight
into our supply chain,
first, I need to
evaluate the risks.
So, I'm focusing
on figuring out how
drought impacts the very
source of our grocery products.
And to do this, I turn to
Google's platform for Earth
science data and
analytics, Earth Engine,
which has a huge catalog of
satellite images for things
like climate, weather,
croplands, and much more.
There's currently over,
like, 50 petabytes
of data in the catalog,
plus more and more images
are added each day.
So, let me just go
ahead and bring up
this cool little application
that I built using the Earth
Engine code editor.
So, I can walk you
through the three
data sets we'll be using today.
First is going to be Crop
Data from the USDA NASS
program, which I can grab right
from the public data catalog
by searching.
So, this data set is going to
contain one image of the US
for each year, going
back all the way to 1997.
And each 10 meter
pixel in this image
has actually been
assigned a crop type.
Let me just close out of this
here, bring you back to my app.
So, the second data set
contains the outline
of agricultural
fields, and we're
going to use Earth Engine to
assign each one of these fields
the crop type that is most
prevalent among the cells that
cover it.
So, in this view that
I'm showing right here,
the pink fields are alfalfa
and the dark green fields
are almonds.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI: Leigha, these
visuals are super helpful,
but could we export
this data for analysis
in other environments?
LEIGHA JARETT:
Yeah, I'm actually
going to push this into
Cloud Storage and BigQuery
in just a sec, but
first, I want to add
in some additional
signals on drought.
So, the third data
set that I'm using
is a collection of both
short and long term drought
indicators.
Meaning that we can
see what drought looks
like for each field over time.
Now, using data sets like these
does require some deep subject
matter expertise.
So, special thanks to
our real world partners,
at Climate Engine,
who build solutions
on top of Earth Engine's
API, helping organizations
ground their analytics projects
with scientifically accepted
methodologies.
OK, so, you just saw how
we use geospatial data.
And I want to know how you
use it in your analysis.
So, go ahead and answer
that poll so we can see.
All right, everyone.
So, with these
layers in place, we
can start exploring
drought risk.
Let me just go ahead
and zoom to this field.
And here I'm going to show
an almond orchard Northeast
of Modesto, California.
And what we're looking at is
the long term drought indicator.
So, this orange tint
that you're seeing
means that this
field has experienced
pretty high levels of drought
over the last five years.
Now, if I go ahead and
just Zoom out a bit,
we can actually see
that the entire Central
Valley in California is
pretty drought stressed.
So, my last step was to
calculate drought risk for each
of the fields I showed before.
And this will tell us
which farms and produce
types are potentially at
risk for not meeting customer
demand, which is just one
consideration to inform
Cymbal's resilience strategy.
Better yet, we can incorporate
this geography data
with other spatial stuff, like
store and customer locations,
that are already
inside a BigQuery,
and anyone who knows me
knows that I love BigQuery.
If you agree, let me
see in the emojis.
All right, so, the
Code Editor has
been great for interacting
with Earth Engine,
but making these
calculations at scale
requires a different approach.
So, I went ahead and
created Earth Engine Tasks
for batch processing, to
run these calculations
over all the data in five-day
increments for the past 10
years.
I also set up a
Cloud function to run
every five days going forward.
So, that we'll always
have fresh data.
Now, just as a quick recap,
we jumped into Earth Engine
to evaluate Earth science
data that indicates climate
risk for our farm fields.
Now, we'll have fresh
drought data available
in Cloud Storage.
So, just think of the
power of integrating
huge amounts of
specialized data,
giving us a complete picture of
supply risk for our business.
Oh, and I think I can see the
poll results coming in now.
It looks like lots of people
are using geospatial data
for all different
kinds of things.
And if your answer
wasn't in the poll,
just go ahead and let
us know in the chat.
So, next up, Brad will
transform and push this data
into BigQuery for geospatial
analysis with our existing
data.
So, Brad, over to you.
BRAD MIRO: OK, that was
pretty cool, Leigha.
Thanks.
All right, so, to
gain more insight
into how drought is
impacting production,
my main focus has been building
out the data transformation
pipeline to push farm field
drought indicators from Cloud
Storage into BigQuery.
Speaking of batch
processing, as you
know, to assist with inventory
management, price optimization,
and product assortment,
we use Spark
to standardize our large
scale data processing.
And we use Google Cloud Dataproc
as our long running clusters.
For you data pros
out there, we'd
love to know how you're
using Spark today.
So, let us know while I go ahead
and pull up the Cloud Console.
So, here is a Dataproc
cluster we currently
use to schedule PySpark jobs.
And here I'm connected
to a Jupyter Notebook,
running on the same cluster
with some PySpark code.
This code is typical
boilerplate code
you'd write to do basic
data transformations.
In this case, we are processing
the Earth Engine files
from Cloud Storage,
performing type checking
and mapping to ensure proper
ingestion into BigQuery using
the Spark BigQuery connector.
LEIGHA JARETT: Hey, Brad.
So, this is pretty
cool, but I think
having a batch workflow
that's scheduled
on a continuously
running cluster
seems like it can
be kind of wasteful.
So, is there any way we can
make this more efficient?
BRAD MIRO: That's a
fair point, Leigha.
There is still some
overhead in management here,
and for hardened
batch cases like this,
it would be preferred
to have these jobs run
on their own discrete resources.
But good news, with the new
serverless option for Dataproc,
we can submit a PySpark
job without spinning up
any infrastructure.
These automagic capabilities,
I can spend more dev time
writing code and less time
on managing infrastructure.
LEIGHA JARETT: All right, Brad.
First off, I'm pretty sure that
you just set me up for that.
And second, you definitely
made up that word, automagic.
BRAD MIRO: Yeah, can I get
the emoji love for that?
Anyway, I'll now go ahead
and export this notebook
to a Python file
using nbconvert.
OK, and next, let's go
and use the Cloud SDK
to submit a serverless
PySpark job.
We can use the Dataproc
API and call batches
to submit a serverless job.
So, I'm showing you
here a PySpark job,
but I can also submit Spark
jobs written in Scala, Java, R,
or SQL.
With auto provision
and auto scale,
no infrastructure
configuration is needed.
This helps those less
familiar with how
to fine tune their
Spark jobs to utilize
its powerful distributed
data processing model.
With these capabilities,
there's no need
to manually create
intune clusters.
So, once I've
submitted the job, I
can show it listed in the
serverless Spark console
and I can click on the
job to view its logs.
Now, serverless Spark
takes about a minute
or so to autoprovision
the resources
as well as start
writing out log output.
So, what I'll go
ahead and do here
is show you the log output
from a completed job
that I ran earlier.
So, if we click in
here, we can see.
OK, so, I added some print
statements into this job.
And here, it's showing me that
there's some short term drought
data that's processed, some
long term drought data,
and then some
geographical data as well.
Now, in addition to this, I can
also show you the Spark history
server, which is where the
more details of the Spark job
itself will be outputted once
the job has been completed.
So, we can go back and debug.
And then additionally,
we can also
gain access to metadata
via Dataproc Metastore.
Now, in addition
to all of this, we
are also looking
into a new solution
for creating long running
clusters or a place where
our infrastructure team can
manage Dataproc clusters.
Now, fortunately, we feel that
Spark on GKE fits our use case
and lets us utilize our
existing GKE infrastructure.
So, clearly, it's
been a busy week
for me using Spark serverless
to create pipelines to push
drought data into BigQuery.
But the efficiency
improvements we'll
gain by not needing to
manage cluster overhead
will be worth it.
Now, you can let
me know in the chat
if you're as excited about
Spark serverless as I am.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI:
OK, let's see how
everyone's using Spark today.
Looks like notebooks
are pretty popular.
LEIGHA JARETT: Oh, and
automation through Airflow.
That's cool too.
OK, great.
Thanks so much, Brad.
So, now that we have greater
insight into supply risks,
we need to scale our transaction
systems to handle more orders
and allow us to understand
the potential business
impact of these climate risks,
while hopefully lowering costs.
So, this brings me
to Derek, our DBA.
Derek, you've been
focusing on this effort.
So, can you let us know
where you're at today?
DEREK DOWNEY: Yeah,
absolutely, Leigha.
We have a new grocery
chain that has
struggled to maintain
their on Prem databases
as they're grown.
There's an opportunity to
solve their underlying scaling
problems with Cloud Spanner.
I spent the last few weeks
validating Spanner's ability
to scale and the
ease of maintenance,
while keeping strong consistency
for this point of sale
workload.
I migrated some of the new
chain stores to Spanner already.
Using granular
instant sizing, I only
provisioned a portion
of a Spanner node
to handle the required load.
As we move the
remainder of the stores,
we can easily scale up without
downtime or app changes.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI:
Quick question, Derek.
We've been really
focused on reducing
the cost and complexity of
building scalable applications.
So, I'm wondering,
how does adding
Spanner impact that effort?
DEREK DOWNEY: Yeah, that's
a great question, Nikita.
One way we've been doing
this in other environments
is to standardize on Postgres.
Postgres is a well established
open source database
with an active ecosystem that
our development and ops teams
are already familiar with.
I tried to get the team
to add an elephant emoji,
so y'all could show some love
for Postgres, but anyway.
Spanner just announced
a PostgreSQL interface.
This gives us the
benefits of Spanner
without having to completely
retrain our application teams.
Having a standard
API for our data
will help us maintain
velocity for new features,
even as our database
needs evolve.
Here, let me show you.
So, I've connected into
our Spanner instance
using the PSQL
command line tool.
From here, I can explore
the schema just like I
would any other database,
any other Postgres database.
You can see that both
the Postgres data
type and the Spanner data type
is available to the information
schema.
So, this will make
it familiar to anyone
who already knows Postgres.
LEIGHA JARETT: Awesome.
Thanks, Derek.
This is really cool.
I'm really looking
forward to the scalability
that this is going
to bring our team.
DEREK DOWNEY: Absolutely.
And as a quick
summary, I highlighted
how Spanner allows us
to get started small
and scale as needed using
granular instant sizing.
And how the new
PostgreSQL interface
reduces friction for our team's
already familiar with Postgres.
Nikita and Leigha, you can treat
the existing data as golden
and I'll keep
onboarding more stores.
Nikita, I believe you need this
data for some of the BigQuery
analysis you were working on.
You've been busy figuring
out how to evolve our ability
to make sense of all this data.
Can you show us how that works?
NIKITA NAMJOSHI:
Yes, absolutely.
I was hoping that you'd ask.
So, to ensure that
we're managing stock
to meet customer demand,
my focus this week
was on evolving our data
science capabilities
for exploratory analysis.
I combine the transactional
data that Derek's
been working on with
the drought data
that Leigha and Brad
pushed into BigQuery.
This way we can gain
insight into which
products are most at risk of
not meeting customer demand.
So, my first step
was to integrate
all of our transactional
data within BigQuery,
primarily using Federation
with Cloud SQL and Spanner.
This provides a
unified environment
for aggregation and analysis
where we can join transactions
back to producer details and the
associated drought risk scores.
Now, as you all
know, we recently
migrated to Vertex
AI Workbench, which
has really, really helped with
our basic compute and resource
management.
DEREK DOWNEY: A quick
question, Nikita.
Is Vertex AI Workbench a
notebook for Vertex AI?
NIKITA NAMJOSHI: That is an
excellent question, Derek.
Vertex AI Workbench contains
recently updated manage
notebooks, which bring
forth more integrated data
engineering capabilities into
our data science environments.
So, we can ingest and
analyze data and deploy
and manage ML models
all from one spot.
Now, let me show you a little
bit about what this looks like.
After I provisioned a
new managed notebook,
my first task was to analyze the
demand on the high volume SKUs.
And for that, I use the BigQuery
connector to view and query
the sales data.
With Vertex AI Workbench, I
can inspect BigQuery metadata,
preview tables, and automate
basic SQL construction entirely
from my notebook environment.
OK, it's my turn on the emojis.
I want to see the fire emoji
from all the data scientists
out there who are
as excited as I
am about being able to access
BigQuery from the notebook
interface.
Looks like I'm not the only one.
BRAD MIRO: Hey, Nikita.
Hold on.
Sorry to interrupt
your emoji fest,
but I see you're working
out of the lakes project,
but are able to pin other
projects you have access to,
like the ops project.
Is that new?
NIKITA NAMJOSHI: Yes,
that's correct, Brad.
Vertex AI Workbench
actually enables
me to interact with all
services via my own identity.
The BigQuery plug-in also
provides some templated code
to help build out queries
and project results
to [INAUDIBLE] data frame.
So, here, we can see-- oh, looks
like I just need to refresh.
Sorry about that, team.
I'm just going to refresh my
Jupyter lab instance here.
I guess I had it
open for too long.
LEIGHA JARETT: And I guess
while Nikita is doing that.
Like, who uses Jupyter now?
Let's see the fire
emojis lighting up.
I see some now.
I personally use it a
lot in my day to day.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI: All right.
Thanks, Leigha.
So, perfect.
Now, you can see a simple
view of all transactions
by the day of week.
And Vertex Workbench
actually also allows
me to launch different kernels
entirely in the same instance.
So, Brad, I think
you were working out
of a PySpark notebook
earlier, is that correct?
BRAD MIRO: Yeah.
So, data Spark clusters
are also supported
as a back end as a part
of Spark on Google Cloud.
We can access all supported
kernels on the cluster,
including PySpark.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI:
Well, for my analysis,
I just needed a Python kernel.
So, let me show you what's
going on in this notebook
and what I've been
up to this week.
You can see here that I've
done a deep dive into the data.
I've plotted the
transaction volume.
I've created a heat
map of purchase counts
across various departments.
And I've also plotted the
short term drought index
across various crop types,
like corn, dry beans, pears,
and rice.
But my last task, and
the most important task,
was to map SKUs to suppliers
and calculate a risk score based
on the aggregate field data.
So, to do this, I started with
our mapping table, which you
can see a sample of right here.
This helped me to determine
which farm fields actually
source ingredients
for a particular SKU.
And then I calculated
a weighted risk score
that takes into account
each product's demand
and the associated farms
overall drought risk.
And you can see each of these
measurements in this data frame
right here.
Ultimately, this score will help
us to prioritize managing items
where we're most at risk of
not meeting customer demand.
So, as a quick summary, I
used Vertex AI Workbench
manage notebooks to
connect back to data
accessible from BigQuery
and create a weighted risk
score for each one
of our products,
combining both climate
and demand data.
Leigha, I went ahead
and put all of this back
into BigQuery, just to
keep it centralized.
LEIGHA JARETT: Awesome.
Thanks so much, Nikita.
That risk score is going to
be huge in helping our team
understand supply risk.
So, to make sure the broader
team has a trusted view of all
this information, I started
incorporating everything
into a Looker dashboard.
Now, with Looker, we define
our metrics, like average risk,
using Look ML,
Looker's data model.
And Looker uses this
to compile SQL queries
and send them back to
BigQuery on our behalf,
so that our
non-technical users can
explore the results
of these data efforts.
So, let me show
you this dashboard
that I've been working on.
And first off, you can
see this custom map layer
that I use to visualize
drought risk across farm
regions in the West.
And we're able to take
advantage of BigQuery's
geospatial functions and
drill from this aggregate view
all the way to producer or
even grocery product level.
Let me show you.
So, I'll drill to field ID.
And then I can jump right
into Looker's Explorer
to bring in some more
fields, like maybe I
want to specifically
look at products
that are at risk in this region
where we're quickly expanding.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI: Making all this
data accessible to the broader
team is really important.
So, can we make sure that the
marketing team is aware of this
so they know how to hold off
on coupons or advertisements
for these products?
LEIGHA JARETT: Yeah.
Actually, we can set up
a schedule from Looker
so that the regional
marketing teams are always
notified if new products
seem to go at risk.
So, putting this
all together, we
used Earth Engine to process
new Earth science data signals.
We used Spark to efficiently
transform geospatial data
and push drought
indicators into BigQuery.
Spanner to scale our
transaction systems, ensuring we
have the infrastructure
to handle future growth.
And Vertex AI
Workbench plus Looker,
backed by the power of BigQuery,
to evolve our data science
capabilities and surface
important trends back
to key decision makers.
So, with integrations
across these services,
anyone is able to
explore and take action
on insights that combine
climate data and transactions.
Now, we can understand
where products
may go out of stock due to
increasing drought conditions
and identify areas
to build resilience
against changes in our climate.
So, with this
geospatial information,
we're given a whole
new set of data,
so that we can not only be
considerate of our customers,
but also find ways to be more
considerate of our planet.
And with that, it looks like
we're right about at time.
So, thank you so much
for joining us today
as we've shown how Google
Cloud can offer a world class
experience for creating
a scalable, unified data
platform.
And a special thanks
to my colleagues,
Nikita for showing us
Vertex AI Workbench,
Derek for introducing us
to Spanner and its Postgres
interoperability, and
Brad for walking us
through Spark on Google Cloud.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI: And
thank you, Leigha,
for showing us Looker
and Earth Engine.
Last but certainly not least,
thank you all out there
so much for your engagement.
We love those emojis and
seeing all of your comments
in the chat.
So, stay tuned for
our live Q&A, which
is going to cover everything
from our spotlight
through this demo.
LEIGHA JARETT: Thank you.
NIKITA NAMJOSHI:
Thanks, everyone.
DEREK DOWNEY: Yeah, thanks.
Bye.